[Music]
let's talk about this movie there's a
scene that's getting a lot of attention
i'm not doing my job if i do not bring
it up you make out with olivia wilde
in in the movie butter please oh yeah
please i didn't tell you the fleet's in
town by the way
um but uh but
this is making men go insane everyone's
talking about this scene uh were you
nervous obviously about shooting that
scene i would think maybe a little bit i
you know i wasn't and i'm glad you
brought this up because part of the
reason i took the role i thought how do
i get a male demographic make out with
olivia wilde right yeah so took the role
um no i would also take that role
that's what every man i've spoken to
says yeah um no i i uh we did it it was
fun and easy she's a good kisser just so
everyone knows um and you know it was a
comedy so we basically there was a ton
of improv and i just did whatever the
director told me to do so you didn't
have to be incredibly intense about it
uh you you could play it for comedy a
little bit yeah and he i mean basically
we would we did it straight once and
then uh he would say okay now roll on
top of her and i was like all right i'm
gonna just do whatever you want who's
this director by the way i know
actually don't do whatever the director
tells you to do if that's what he's
saying we have a clip here from butter
and i think this is a scene where your
character first sees olivia well is that
right yes
let's take a look at this clip from
butter
[Music]
hey boo you can't be here no but you
still owe me money remember i never got
the rest of the money
ain't free this isn't happening but you
said you loved me bob that was a little
early for me but we did it i never do it
with guys from the club
dad
who's that
nobody
nobody
is
she's a recruiter
[Applause]